les templiers un ordre de moines soldats
éliminé par le biais de la
désinformation
[Musique]
au 14ème siècle à la fin des croisades
lisant ces moines soldats qui étaient
les templiers rentrer en europe et
s'installe un petit peu partout dans des
monastères
ils vont y développer des entreprises
très lucrative de prêts bancaires
ils vont prêter à des gens très fortunés
des nobles des seigneurs et même des
rois c'est notamment le cas de philippe
le bel
le roi de france au début du 14e siècle
qui est très endetté en raison de ces
guerres contre l'angleterre
il a fait des emprunts aux templiers et
leur dois donc beaucoup d'argent
de plus il est en colère en fait contre
cet ordre religieux parce que les
monastères ne paie pas d'impôt sur son
territoire comment ne pas payer ses
dettes et même récupérer les terres des
régies templiers la désinformation la
fausse rumeur et larmes que vaut
privilégier fait des plus belles à ce
moment là ils me répondent la fausse
rumeur que les templiers crache sur la
croix rni le christ vont même jusqu'à
pratiquer la sodomie
la rumeur se répand et les gens veulent
en avoir le coeur net et on demande donc
au pape à l'époque clément simple
d'ouvrir un procès afin d'interroger des
templiers sur leurs pratiques qu'on
considérait donc à l'époque comme
hérétique
le parc clemenceau qui à l'époque ne
crois pas que les temples dit plus
commettre de tels actes qui connaît très
bien les moines soldats alors ils
refusent au départ de commencer un
triple belle de donc trouver une
solution il va décider de torture et les
templiers
alors le vendredi 13 octobre 1307 le roi
de france procède à l'arrestation des
templiers de france et sous la torture
plusieurs vont confessé admettre avoir
pratiqué les risées alors au terme du
procès que le pape clément 5 sera obligé
de mettre en place
on va réaliser que le grand responsable
de tous ces crimes le grand maître de
l'ordre du temple jeunes de mollet qui
sera brûlée sur le bûcher
alors on a ici utilisé la fausse
nouvelle comme une arme afin de se
débarrasser d'un ennemi et philippe le
bel ou terme de cet exercice récupère
les terres des templiers et ne pas payer
ses dettes
d'ailleurs le vendredi 13 depuis ce
temps est associé en france un jour de
malchance